[موسيقى]
حسنا اذا كنت تقصدين ذلك على وجه العموم
فانت محقه اذا لا توجد قدره لاي شخص لمنع
كارثه وازمه من الحدوث لكننا تعلمنا
الدروس ما سمح لنا بفهم الازمات حيث لدينا
شيء نسميه عقدا اجتماعيا عندما تنعدم
الثقه بين الناس وحكوماتهم فلا يصدق هذا
الطرف والطرف الاخر بما يدفع الصعوبه الى
النائب نفسي عن مؤسسات الدوله فذلك يعني
انذارا مبكرا على كوننا في وضع يرجح فيه
بصفه عاليه تحدث ازمه او نزاع ربما بسبب
تنافسا عرقي او خلاف دينيه او خلافات
تاريخيه بشان الاراضي كل هذا يمكنك توقعه
وبالتالي التحذير منه في تقارير واقتراح
حلول او غيرها
[موسيقى]
جزءا من مداخلتي في منتدى الرياض الدولي
الانساني على كيفيه التوقع بشكل افضل
اثناء الازمات الطارئه بما يسمح بتجنب
النزاعات وبكيفيه مبسطه جدا فان الاستثمار
في التنميه يبدو هو الوسيله الانجح لتلافي
الازمات والنزاعات حيث يمكنك دائما منعها
كما انه ايضا السبيل الامثل لتجاوز
الازمات والخروج منها وهذا ما يجعلنا نفهم
ان انقاذ الحياه او مساعده الناس على
الخروج من الازمه ليس اهم من منع حدوثها
فقط والطريق على اسبابها افضل ولذلك فان
منح الحلول في الوقت الملائم اهم حيث انه
مثلا عندما توفر العداله بين الجهات فانت
ستكون قد تحركت بكيفيه مبكره وملائمه بما
ينزع فتيل الموقف
[موسيقى]